If you are into very simple but delicious food,...
...and if you don't need any fancy ingredients and culinary extravagance,...
...a visit to Vis, one of the Croatian islands, might be it.
With traditional cuisine, tiny restaurants and a "life in the slow lane" motto,...
...this island has established a modest corner on the tourist market.
The seasons, the weather and the endless blue ocean...
...characterize the lifestyle.
The main ingredients of the local cuisine are...
...blue fish and vegetables, salted sardines...
...and grilled fresh sardines on a spit.
The idea is to have as little waste as possible.
Vegetables are cooked and bottled,...
...and fruits are made into jam or spiced and dried.
Fish stock is used for bean stew.
The dishes are delicious...
...because of this plainness and excellence of the raw materials.
The effort the local people expend on nurturing their fields...
...as well as on the cooking process makes the food exceptional.